I bought a piano just so I could hear
the sound of my children like slamming
their fingers into it I just love that
noise God you like that noise I love it
oh I love it like one of the things I
kept saying in this last year like last
year um my entire personality became
Golf and it kind of became like a joke
for a while and so I was trying to be
but what I wanted to do was be better at
being like being good at not being great
at something like that is what I've
really wanted to be better at and I and
I remember being like I want my kids to
be able to just play messy keys on a
piano and not have to be like no this
sounds good and this sounds bad because
when you're creating art like I I would
just be paralyzed by like a white piece
of paper and if I started something that
I had decided like wasn't the way it was
supposed to turn out I'd be like well
then what's the point